♪ ♪
>> Bret: WE CONTINUE OUR
REGULATION NATION SERIES WITH A
LOOK AT HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
CUTTING OF FEDERAL RED TAPE.
CORRESPONDED DOUG McKELWAY
TELLS US HOW THAT WOULD WORK.
>> THE BRIDGE IS A SIMPLE OF
WHAT AILS U.S. INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE FIRST ENVIRONMENT TO IMPACT
STUDIES TAKEN TO RAISE THE
ROADWAY TO ALLOW SHIPS TO PASS
UNDERNEATH.
THE STUDIES TOOK FIVE YEARS AND
GENERATED 2,000 PAGES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT AND
ANOTHER 10,000 PAGES OF
PREVENTING.
THE PROJECT IS NOT SLATED FOR
COMPLETION UNTIL 2019.
>> WE BUILT THE EMPIRE STATE
BUILDING IN JUST ONE YEAR.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TRYING TO CUT THROUGH SUCH
RED TAPE AS IT PROPOSES A
$1.5 TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM.
>> THE POLITICAL WILL HAS NOT
BEEN THERE.
>> YOU HAVE TO TAKE ON A LOT OF
LAWYERS, ENVIRONMENT GROUPS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN HE'S
NOT AFRAID OF IT.
>> FOUR DAYS AFTER HIS
INAUGURATION THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED A MEMORANDUM TO BEGIN
STREAMLINING.
THE WHITE HOUSE CITED THIS STUDY
IS ITS ROAD MAP AND FOUND THE
PERMITTING PROCESS SO CUMBERSOME
IT SOMETIMES HARMS THE
ENVIRONMENT BY DELAYING
CONSTRUCTION.
"AMERICA'S ANTIQUATED PART POWER
GRID WASTE THE EQUIVALENT OF 200
BURNING POWER PLANTS OR
$150 BILLION PER YEAR."
IN SUBSEQUENT MEMORANDA, THE
WHITE HOUSE PROMISED TO
ESTABLISH A ONE AGENCY, ONE
DIVISION STRUCTURE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
SHORTEN THE LENGTH OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS TO
TWO YEARS AND ELIMINATE
REDUNDANT PROVISIONS IN
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND THEIR
WASHINGTON ALLIES SAY IT'S THE
WRONG APPROACH.
>> I WOULD NEVER ARGUE FOR A
SLOWER PERMITTING PROCESS BUT
THE WAY TO MAKE IT FASTER IS TO
FUND THE AGENCIES THAT ALREADY
HAVE THE CHARGE OF PUTTING
PERMIT THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
>> THE TRUMP PLAN GIVES MORE
POWER TO THE STATES WHO HAVE
LEARNED THEY NEED TO MAKE
PERMITTING EASIER TO BE
COMPETITIVE.
>> STATES HAVE LED THE WAY.
THEY OFTEN MOVE TOWARDS THINGS
LIKE ONE-STOP SHOPPING,
CONCIERGE SERVICES.
>> TRUMPS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROMISES WILL BE HARD TO KEEP.
AFTER HE GAVE THE GO-AHEAD TO
COMPLETE THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE ERGO, IT REMAINS